[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute le léger swing de la machine à
coudre ne sont plus un petit barry de la
lessive en poudre
quelque 4 ans la raquette à battre les
tapis fait un flop ce sont les coaches
aurait pas dû lire
la rythmique des appareils ménagers les
orages de la machine à laver
[Musique]
les empêchant ainsi de bien écouter même
les cracks sur le bois du plancher
même le commun des mortels
[Musique]
en deçà seiichi duquel
il ya dans ce secteur des ondes de
musique qui circulent peut-être inquiet
jusqu'au bris
[Musique]
le tout la pop demande la 4 e tiers
programmables intarissable les verts
[Musique]
looking at the grove eux dans les tuyaux
bière glacée qui teinte dans le trio
[Musique]
goûter sans cédric armato bien musique
mélange texas et le nouveau mexique
[Musique]
même le commun des mortels
en tout ça c'est ridicule
[Musique]
à
chauffez pavillon de soleil andré on
sent le canapé dans ce sens bouger des
quatre garçons sont prêts à s'envoler
pendant que doucement entre la lumière
vol imperceptiblement la poussière
[Musique]
une paire de boots en daim coiffée des
claquettes feuille de temps du nrj
secrète
même le commun des mortels
[Musique]
entend s'acquitter coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de haut
à m'asseoir sur un banc 100 minutes avec
toi et regarde les gens tant qu' on a
parlé du bon temps qui est mort qui
reviendra en serrant dans ma main et
petit doigt
me donner à bouffer à des pigeons idiot
lors filer des coups de pied pour de
faux
et entendre ton rives qui lézardent les
murs qui s'est surtout guérir mais
blessure
devra continuer un peu comment cheminot
les montbel fabuleux
compliqué chez marchand quand ça qui
mine tout comme elle un franc
et mistral gagnant
[Musique]
en marché sous la pluie cinq minutes
avec toi et regarde la vie tant qu'il y
en a
[Musique]
te raconter la terre en te bouffe
ambitieux te parler le thème petit peu
sauter dans les flaques pour la faire
râler bousiller nos deux gas et ce
marais
et entendre tout rives comme on entend
le même s'arrêter reparti en
tout raconter surtout tard en battant
les cocobohème
les vrais roudoudou qui nous coupent
élèves et nous les dents
mistral gagnant
[Musique]
ans
asseoir sur un banc cinq minutes avec
toi garder le soleil qui s'en va
te parler du coton qui mange je m'en
fous te dire quel show c'est pas nous
je sais moi je suis d'armes ce n'est que
tu de tes yeux ils ont l'avantagé d'être
deux
et entendre ton riz s'envoler aussi haut
que s'envolent et cris des oiseaux
te raconter enfin qui faute aimait la
vie et les mais même si
le temps est assassin et emporte avec
lui le rire les enfants
graviano
mistral gagnant
[Musique]
merci
cette peur qu'il me déshabille
pour avoir osé tout sur ma peau et ses
pleurs qui te thema qui
viennent ont porté ma raison sous le
flou malgré tout les regards qui firent
près de nous les temps gars qui vacille
après tout son macbook mac mac magma
ça ira mieux
çà et là pour toujours
[Musique]
nous allons réclamer mon cerveau je dis
ça ira mon amour
[Musique]
n'oubliera les tours
surtout écrire de le libérer
[Musique]
vers nos corps qui se touchent
car c'est l'esprit de nos idéaux j'ai
posé ma langue sur ta bouche
savourer les sens de thé moindre mot
malgré tout le désir est fragile près de
nous
plaisir de
après tout pour son mac mac mac magma
ça ira mal
que ça ira pour toujours
ah les amendes etc la meinau cerdon
tiers tout
ça ira mon amour
que n'oubliera les temps
surtout le mur j'écrivais je le liberté
chérie
[Musique]
mon
amour
c'est un avis que j'épouse
ce jour
sortie de roses rouges mâles 11
il faut rire et danser
voilà le printemps
libéré
cinq rames
écrira le crush
je t'offrirai mais pour la vie promis
ça ira mon amour
ça ira pour toujours
[Musique]
à
lausanne ont déclamé non seulement en
partie
ça ira mon amour
est noble et soum
sur tous les murs j'écris des jeux le
jeu sortir
jerry
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]